so I guess for me the big issue is a
standout 1 I read the news and
newspapers is issues having to do with
violations of human rights corrupt
governments around the world still
caused an enormous amount of pain
suffering death and I think some
progress has been made in that area you
know it's it's very difficult now to
imagine Europe in a state of war and
just last century we had just a huge
enormous bloodbath in Europe and things
seem to have stabilized there and that's
a good thing so I always try to remind
people that five years ago I was just
some guy sitting at home in my pajamas
typing on the internet and now I get us
all these big picture deep guru
questions about the future of the world
and so forth you know I think a lot of
the challenges that face the world in
the next five to ten years are you know
pretty obvious things basically trying
to figure out how to contain the threat
of terrorism without destroying freedom
that's a that's a big very complicated
issue that I don't think anybody has all
of the answers for I think we have a few
things we we know don't work but we do
them anyway so the excessive excessively
paranoid security at airports doesn't
seem to be doing any good whatsoever to
me but well I don't see a stopping doing
that anytime soon but I think that you
know one of the challenges that we face
is to realize that you know military
solutions to those problems are woefully
inadequate there may be times when
military action is necessary or are
worth doing but it's it's hardly the
right answer in a lot of cases and it
certainly is never the fundamental and
the fundamental answer always has to be
education dialogue learning not just us
learning about them but but also us
teaching them it goes both ways of
course but I think it's important to
realize that there is a certain brand of
irrationality which is extremely
dangerous it's you know when we think of
some some group like the Taliban and it
you know they're they're gross
violations of human rights in the name
of religion are just completely
unconscionable in that we cannot in the
name of a you know spirited
multiculturalism which is a fine thing
but you cannot go down a path that says
well gee that's just a different way of
living and it's kind of ok to stone
people to death for being homosexuals
it's not okay it's completely wrong and
we have to stand firm in that even
though well how do we fix that problem
that's it's not easy
facing the less than the next decade I
think the US has a lot of work ahead in
changing our public image around the
world I think it's been a real problem
in the last last 10 years or so even
longer than that the the the fact that
we have you know such a massive and
undisputed military superiority has
tempted our leaders to go down military
paths to solve problems that really are
not military problems this in turn has
given rise to an enormous amount of
ill-will around the world and a
forgetting on our part and on the part
of other people around the world what
the u.s. really could and should stand
for symbolically we traditionally you
know that the traditional American
values of freedom of speech of
toleration of different kinds of people
living together in peace of being a
melting pot culturally of you know a
real value for education and higher
education in particular all those kinds
of values are really important still
around the world and are something that
we should be much more projecting that
benevolent side of what it means to be
American right so that it can be
something that people look to us as say
you know this is actually a model of a
society that I would like to live in and
I would like to change my world to be
something more like that we have that
opportunity but it gets lost if our
answer to a problem around the world as
always to send in the Bombers right so I
think that's an enormous challenge is to
really think about how do we communicate
that those values are our good values
and that they're still here they're
still among this many times I see people
overseas who simply assume that freedom
of speech is under you know is dead in
the US the Patriot Act is sort of a
created a police state well it's
completely not true patriotic has some
problematic provisions but it's fairly
minor in the grand scheme of things
things that need to be fixed to be sure
but
still have this open vibrant democracy
that we have the opportunity to to to
shine around the world if only we will
testa I think you know in in the short
term I think that our you know both
political parties are so problematic in
so many ways that it's really difficult
to to say what issues they could even
plausibly address in their current state
you know certainly there are some very
practical issues that have to be dealt
with obviously the situation in Iraq is
currently quite a mess and somebody's
got to do something about it right we
don't have a choice of making it go away
and so you know the question of do we
commit more resources there that we
commit fewer resources there that we
leave do we what do we do how do we do
it that's obviously very important and
of course has an impact on all the other
things that I was talking about about
our image abroad how do we educate
people in the values that are beneficial
and well I wouldn't invading anybody to
try to figure out how to get us to a
better place in the Iraq situation so
that's clearly an issue that I
personally will be very interested in
hearing from the candidates about you
know I think some of the simple answers
just don't make any sense to me you know
the simple answer of let's just pull out
all our troops tomorrow and go home wow
that sounds unbelievably immoral to
leave the situation they are completely
wrecked and clearly to fall under the
hands of the worst possible thugs very
bad idea okay well what does that mean
keep doing what we're doing it doesn't
seem to be working so well send three
times as many troops over that doesn't
seem like a great idea either I don't
know the answer right so we're in this
really tough situation and I'm really
looking for somebody to come up with
some new innovative solutions that I
think sound useful and I don't think
there's going to be anything that make
everything wonderful there it's too late
for that but hopefully we can we can do
the most ethical things possible and try
to help I mean I think a lot of a lot of
innovation just happens when you get the
government out of the way so a lot of
times when people talk about encouraging
innovation what they end up thinking
about way too much is you know some
massive public subsidies for some new
chip manufacturing something something
and it's usually a complete and total
fiasco because you get the wrong types
of people coming in the wrong types of
politically connected businesses doing
things that make no sense because
they're being subsidized to do it I
think it's really important to recognize
that it's very very difficult for the
government to do anything to encourage
innovation the most important thing we
can do with this get out of our way